foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you're going on a date with Lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock I have
an owner he's Superman
[Music]
my dog's the best or but he's not the
greatest with other animals this just
seems gross we need gross smelling stuff
is one of the greatest joys of being a
dog next to licking any part of your
body and I lick myself all the time well
that explains the breath
Superman I am Lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
you're invulnerable I should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
Cutie Pops
working at The Kinks I didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs never Feed Us
chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumb owner back
hey deploy canine Shield what is a
canine
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why can't I have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do I have here
squeezy bro scratch that better be a
licensed toy or I will freak out
[Music]
foreign